mmm dink-dink thank you thank you
welcome back to the gingiva Park is this
a dream did you wake me up out of a
dream
yes oh my god Chris smell booger yo he's
taking over the podcast we did it guys
welcome to the podcast oh you're in the
middle that's the rule that is the rule
I didn't make them except we made them
anyway welcome back to the gentleman
podcast this week we have special guests
Chris Mel burger good friend streamer
tick-tock er creator of neat dude the
brand that we literally wear every
single day that you see on Jenna's shirt
my shirt Jenna's beanies I mean we you
pretty much have clothed us for years
now yeah thank you by the way for that
hey anytime Chris is visiting in town
right now actually you have a flight in
like an hour so yeah so whoa thanks very
much yeah yeah no we're flying out and a
little bit well more than that he's a
third time he's third or fourth this is
my first time solo oh shanz not here
sorry can is she mad she's not sure
watching go
okay Jenny mad okay anyway this week we
have me undies Thank You Mia nice
response from the podcast guys they're
promoting their feel free collection
tested on every body type yes real body
types not the perfectly proportioned
mannequin type they're offering sizes
extra small to 4 XL go to meet undies
calm / Jenna Julian get 15% off your
first pair of free shipping and 100%
satisfaction guarantee also stitch fix
if you love clothes and you don't love
shopping stitch fixes for you you enter
your style preferences and they
basically assign a professional stylist
to you and your account and then they
send you clothes that they are paid to
know that you will like so go to stitch
fix calm / - no Julian and you'll get an
extra 25% off when you keep all items in
your box or click the link down below in
the description box there's a lot of
[ __ ] dogs in this room let me just say
that there's five yeah five dollars in
this room you know what I'm fairly
certain that that's the most dogs that's
ever been
this room at once by far I think it's
the most dogs that have ever been on a
podcast oh that's true we can we can we
register that with the Guinness Book
yeah five dogs in a podcast.com okay
well that's that's got some like you
dogs chillin and a podcast
five feet apart cuz the bark because
they bark
I'll buy the euro right now okay
no yeah like while you're in the pocket
now someone's gonna buy it after this
podcast for sure well we have a day head
start that goes up tomorrow let's go
okay we know we're doing at the airport
anyway chris is here you were here for
some business stuff some on the side we
hung out which was a lot of fun there's
a lot of cool things coming with me dude
a lot of cool things come with me dude
for sure but in case this is the first
podcast anyone's ever seen of you you
are a person who came from vine I guess
it's safe to say yeah and now you are
twitch streamer and you make content on
tick tock which actually is like doing
really well and yeah people are enjoying
it and I just started in a tick tock
with Chris so now it's Julian also I'm a
tick talker yeah okay to call myself no
that's fine yeah we yeah I think she's
happy about it can you tell everybody
forever ago cuz Chris knows how much I
love vine and forever ago Chris was like
you gotta check out tick tock like you'd
really like it like I think you think
it's really funny and I still thought
tick tock was like musically where it's
just like lip synching and stuff like I
didn't get it I didn't I didn't really
enjoy musically but then once I got on
tick tock and realized that it was
[ __ ] hysterical it I loved it my ron
eclis love it you all know that I love
it
yeah I feel like SH and myself and a few
other people I know will be on there for
hours before the back bed yeah I [ __ ]
laugh my ass off on there it's really
it's really cool it's very different to
I feel like it's it there's a lot of
similar vibe behind vibes but it's also
its own medium now and I think a lot of
people there's a lot of people who are
like stuck in the old ways we're like I
don't care I'm not gonna check it out
but like there's a lot of funny stuff on
there well I think like you Jenna talk
to us a lot but I think she makes a good
point that's like in the vine days vine
wasn't as cool as it is
after vine had died like a note became
popularized a lot more a popular vines
that I'm sure are in whatever vine quiz
were playing didn't really like blow up
until they were on YouTube in
compilations yeah like they weren't the
same on the platform and so I feel like
this is a similar thing happening with
technologies like vine legends yeah
there's like these I don't know people
who just don't want to jump on tech talk
because they don't think it's cool or
they think it's for kids or whatever but
the reality is there's a lot of really
really funny content on there right now
but that's what people thought about
vine when vine was alive that it was
cringy and stupid yeah and I got me fun
of I got made fun of for everyone
especially top youtubers who are all
like vines [ __ ] stupid it's six
seconds and you can't monetize on it and
I'm like whatever shut up [ __ ]
sterile no it's weird it's like I
remember that - I remember the the vibe
that youtubers a lot of designers yeah
but but on the contrary I remember the
first time we met Viners ie you what was
like five six years ago and then we
member went to a 4th of July party with
like all the miners like my best friend
Scott he's saying I mean everyone the
first time we met and I was blown away
at how nice everyone was to us because I
was expecting it to just be like kind of
hostile but that they were so nice and I
was like what the hell why is this nice
they're still nice yeah and some of the
biggest youtubers have stayed nice more
Viners truth I don't think a legitimate
amount of them like like no David Danny
drew Cody no all those guys were for
sure
not the Paul's not even Emily Michaela
long like legitimately like no yeah a
ton and yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
drew Philips like all these kids yeah
it's cool I tried YouTube we made we
give it a shot well I mean you've sort
of found out a home on Twitch yeah is
like it's one thing to be like streaming
on Twitch and then putting highlights on
YouTube and that's how you have both but
it's another thing to be like a youtuber
and to a super yeah and it's just
[ __ ] hard it's hard it's definitely
hard to go the way of like building a
twitch channel an audience
then trying to like parlay that on the
YouTube as well I mean you've been doing
YouTube for a long time and some of your
sketches have absolutely blown up on the
internet oh for sure but it's just hard
it's hard to do both because it's a lot
of time for both it's also just
completely different audiences some
people don't give a crap whether your
games totally and some people don't give
a crap about sketches so it's like I
have like two different people sets of
audiences is shown I can relate to that
yeah people who like cooking people who
like tarkov yeah no you're right and
there's a little medium in between maybe
there is there's there's a hardcore fan
crossover that just kind of shows up
everywhere but everybody likes vines
that's I guess that brings us to if you
don't well here's what happened right I
was talking to you right and I was like
what should we do with the Christmas
podcast and I asked Twitter and sorry
but you were no help is that coffee or
tea no I appreciate that I appreciate
the suggestions but I think when you
guys when I'm like hey we have a guest
on the podcast what do you want to do
and some of you say play
hide-and-go-seek around the house with
the dog play jackpot CD with three
people yeah yeah it's I appreciate it
and I think that content would be funny
in a world where we could execute it but
literally were three people at a table
that me a YouTube video Mike yeah as a
YouTube video and also we don't have we
don't have the time resources to kind of
whatever so anyway I was talking to
Jenna I was like a Chris and both of
them just were non-stop non-stop smack
talking each other that they knew vine
better than the other I mean Chris I'm
not smack talking I'm genuinely scared I
feel like Chris is the only person
because he was in that world that's like
if you quiz me about like old YouTube
I'd probably know a lot more than a lot
of other people because you've like met
the people or worked with them you have
like spoken to them you have more
personal connection so it's easier to
remember sir it's old YouTube also
challenge you want to go for me happy
burger season by the way maybe keep this
off the edge of the table
old YouTube was a whole different ball
game mm-hmm yeah but you know I think
the vending the vine I'm curious
she's very your Jenna's very good at
vine good trivia she's really good but
I'm scared and I'm also I'm not brushed
up like it's been a minute because I am
fully submerged
to talk right now Sam are you submerged
in the dope tick-tocks that we've been
making dude we made two tic TOCs one
hasn't even gotten live yet we had a
boys day yesterday it was fun we did we
had a boys day baby we had a boys day I
was in the game room playing house we
had a boy's day we went to a million
different places we got you a free shirt
yeah he went and got Taco Bell we got
maybe a tattoo I'm a nighttime tattoos
do a really shifty place where we were
talking to you I understand the way that
the sentence came out though you
literally came into the game room you
said to me hey babe we're gonna go buy a
whole food to get some supper dinner and
we might get a tattoo after obviously
yeah we went to Whole Foods and got like
a bunch of vegan hamburger supplies
ingredients and then I got a tattoo
immediately after I mean you know what
sometimes you got to understand this is
my third tattoo I've gotten with Chris
and I think that's kind of special like
I know you're not a tattoo person but I
know you did but I know you also
appreciate tattoos and you appreciate
the fact that we've made now three
memories getting tattoos together that's
a cool thing we're gonna get 10 to 15 10
to 15 before we die yeah Julie yesterday
it was like babe you wanna come get
tattoos and first so I'm like no we have
five dogs here like one of them's hurt
marbles by the way something's going on
with his tail he has something called
dead tail where his tail just like hangs
down could be a sprain tail I don't he
could have impacted anal glands I don't
know but like a couple of our dogs are
in need of like a little bit of
supervision yeah I'm Julie is like but
babe don't you want to make memories and
I was like listen I like memories but
like no I don't want to tattoo and we
have so many dogs here well no I just
want to defend myself here okay I'm not
irresponsible I've been taking care of
the dogs day and night and if we have
left all of them in their current
condition for about hour and a half when
we went to Bed Bath & Beyond that was a
fun trip
by the way family trip to better air
fryer we got an air fryer
shy should I say what happened or no
yeah no don't expose me on my own
podcast that's fine go ahead yeah so we
were definitely good I've been got to be
on with a John noob Kohner we need to
end the pal and we're looking for stuff
and you want to go buy a blender right I
wanted to buy a new vitamin
well actually I should rewind further
why I need a new Vitamix um i eated mine
across the kitchen and there's a hole in
the bottom of it
he dropped it I dropped it cuz I was
trying to do the thing where you flip it
in the air and then you slide your hand
in where they handle hole is and you
catch it and you're just like damn dude
don't go on them and I missed and I just
I just went eating across the cross
Allah and I picked it up and I was like
oh sorry babe sorry for the noise
because I was like oh that's fine
plastic so I put it on the on the stand
on the power thing fill it up with ice
for a protein powder and then I'm like
okay I pour the liquid in and it's just
it's not raising I mean you know when
you have like the yeah it should be like
going up it should be gone and it's not
I'm like am I just like that tired I
like I go and then I just start getting
wet it's all over the coffee at people
okay the coffee house what I was pouring
in to make sure it was all over the
counter and then there was just coffee
everywhere in the kitchen and then I was
like oh we broke the blender well ok
what you're running Dewar's on the
blender that from my perspective was
super loud unnecessary noise all the
dogs get upset they start running around
you sorry babes alright you go over
there you start getting everything
everywhere and then unlike you I watched
you pour it from here onto the floor
basically you had a different view and
they just let me burn yeah absolutely
oh it's kind of funny to watch probably
right yeah I mean I imagine if you were
in anyone's viewpoint but mind it would
get funny I don't like oh so you just
saw it happening yes yeah continue with
the method beyond we see we see a price
tag for this air fryer two and one toe
they don't have the blender so yeah we
moved on and you like I could use one of
those that sounds cool and John's like
yeah it's great dude I have that at home
it's awesome it makes great stuff and
doing awesome so you see the price tag
you grab the box underneath it's a huge
box you pay for it we leave that's it
we're like school we got an air fryer in
there for her you take another box when
we get back you're all Excel you put it
on there and you're like huh
where's the air fryer Iraq and Jon's
like yeah what the hell and then Jen and
I are like huh and then we look at the
box and then you're realize it's just
like that's a regular toaster oven so
and I open the box like an ape yeah so
stuff everywhere so that happened and so
then I he sit all back together in the
box somehow yeah
taped it up brought it back and we got
the airfryer so long story short we got
an air fryer it was very easy and
everything went as planned we had
Brussels sprouts sprouts and I made air
fried tofu we almost have fried your
phone it was yeah it was a wild night
yeah yeah all that from a sandal maybe
we had a boys days a business boys night
monkey we talk about stuff what's the
first ones are breaking bad wait I stole
that from you thanks we made to tik toks
babe I just took some food photography
did you see the comment on that no I
posted a picture of the burger do you
see the picture yes really good burger
really good burger and also really good
comment it's guy named canine [ __ ]
comment I want to put this inside
someone oh my god and he's a very
intimidating looking guy and the profile
page so I shared the comment so there we
go signal boost to you keen on [ __ ] my
dude yeah but definitely not scary yeah
but it's a great comment it's probably
so many good ones on there you should
honestly do a video about all the funny
comments you got in food pictures fat on
that oh wow
post a bunch of sick like food porn and
then just get to see the funny comment
that's [ __ ] good and then they're
gonna flow in even more cuz people know
I make a video and they're gonna try
making funny when it's the jacksFilms
effect where I'm getting funny
commenters yeah they're gonna be in the
video right yeah yeah thanks are you
familiar with who it is okay any we
don't talk about him on the pocket sir
um anyway we have a couple of vine
quizzes some from the internet some not
from the internet and so I figured we
would just kind of go through them I
have some rules okay I have some rules
no rules well here's what I was thinking
we could do a lightning round okay right
where are you gonna individually ask us
question no it's a dual lightning round
it's whatever shots it out first but the
rest of it and if we tie no points to
the rest of it is I'm asking you
individually and the way it's gonna go
is I'll start with one of you what if I
know his and if you don't know it it
goes to Chris you can't shout it out
while it's our turn good vice versa so
if I say Jenna you know vine question
number one and you don't know the answer
it goes to Chris
and if you get it it's your okay and
it's why I'm gonna make a scoreboard
it's gonna be we're just doing one point
for each correct answer and then we'll
do a lightning round
okay and then oh okay so then when we do
the lightning round if I think that you
guys have answered on a tie like if you
shout out the same exact time and I
can't differentiate who's first you have
to know I changed this oh you have to do
an impression of it and whoever does the
better reenactment of the vine wins
that's funny that's good right yeah I
like that
so Oh God okay I'm getting ready I'm
getting ready
mmm I love this madrenas coffee good old
cold brew okay all right here we got 30
questions 30 questions I'm gonna start
with Jenna okay and we're gonna babe
this is easy come on country blank I
love you I love you got it Chris her
give me a point I'm sorry I forgot about
the points Chris yeah Hurricane Katrina
more like hurricane tore Atilla my kids
probably in college that was mine oh I
want a church girl that go to church
blank and wiener my mom hey hey sorry
you were the one you guys this is the
others in the bag
welcome to blank blank we're all
children of Jesus Bible Camp it's wrong
it's funny incorrect Jenna Bibles oh
yeah I'm second guessing it's either
school or study I haven't given you an
answer 5 cool both incorrect Bible Camp
Gibson Michael school they're wrong
whatever I was Christine yes
Jib bigger ones she had the potenti said
it was adderall yeah okay
it was funny God dang it that's
embarrassing wait yeah we [ __ ] up like
that we [ __ ] up we [ __ ] up okay cut
this out right
this one is literally just one work
ready it says mrs. blank hmm give me to
read the options is this for me yes for
you it's for Jenna
yeah what are the options valentino
Keisha potatoes yeah I lose okay Chris
right yeah not to be racist or anything
but that's it
hey hold on oh my god Jenna knows it
Jenna knows that you only need the first
like the first like part of this not to
be racist or anything but blank dude wow
I have no idea oh my god Jenna okay see
you please do not take this out of
context of I'm answering the vine but
Asian people suck
that's that's a vine that's a vine I
never saw that where [ __ ] where turns
like the effect goes on and she looks
like she's in outer space when she's
screaming I never I leave aerosol on one
alright jenna is winning damn okay so
cups you have a long time Chris yes hi
welcome to Chili's well done Thank You
Jenna oh it [ __ ] it timed me and then
it just quit god damn it okay oh yeah
time to me out okay I'm sorry I could
have dropped my croissant stop I could
have dropped sorry no sorry okay Jenna
you lose the point first I was the vodka
can I get a blank can I please get up
link blank can I please get a blank oh
[ __ ]
I'm [ __ ] yeah I don't know this either
is there other options mm there are
there's a lot of them I don't know which
one this is
can I get a bike I can't I get a blanket
to him what this was
wait Wednesday is it oh yeah oh yeah
is that Alyssa violet I don't see that I
just don't see I don't honestly don't
see any answers that looks like would be
for this community so no the answer is
true soon it looks like that it's like a
word jumble and I have to pick the right
word because all of these correspond to
one hole you can't look cuz those
correspond to other questions those
answers well they're different let's
just do different what that's skipper
well nine you know what it is blank stop
another really good okay you know the
answer it's Chris's turn right yeah
blink stop oh my god wait it's like it's
someone's name mm-hmm cope sir I think
he begins with a B or D oh god it's a
kid kicking yeah oh [ __ ] is his name
he's kicking everywhere and he gets
arrested at the by the cops is he on P
what you're not allowed to do that I'm
do whatever wants my quiz winter time up
when's his time here five seconds Oh
five g's a G right to one stop it Zach
that's that what since when dear that I
i why i watched a different one
[Laughter]
I'm the worst you're not the worst you
hold on you need to remember here this
is our table Jenna has home-field
advantage okay
Jill you're on a foreign turf chair on
our podcast there's more pressure on you
sure and she's you know she bike assumes
lines one day no she's also getting a
little rowdy here so I'm gonna give you
a formal warning here Jenna in this in
this competition maybe maybe act like
you've been there before
okay let's keep it civil now I was
talking trash I guess I don't need a
degree to because
you look like that that that meme of
your eyes are they're really tiny when
you're doing this you know what that is
such a funny image
your turn Jenna okay I don't need a
degree to become a blank closing
correct dude I'm [ __ ]
ladies and gentlemen welcome to alright
[ __ ] reset me I know the answer though
ladies and gentlemen welcome to okay
well if you don't get it and then no one
gets appointment wait means for me no
it's Chris but if you don't get it
ladies and gentlemen welcome to to
target oh let's go okay shut up in San
Marcos okay let's do that
you can vision the voice from yeah
that's that's it girl guess what they
got here girl guess what they got here
girl
guess what they got here is this free
ship free shabat gadol cuz i don't think
that's how it starts
I don't think that I don't think that's
it no I could try it let's see no no
it's not free - back today hmm girl
you're something out here I'm gonna pass
okay I don't know the answer grace I
feel like it's I don't know like two for
one it's like a food thing but I don't
know either to be honest I'll just redo
girl guess what they got here
waffle potato the fee savvy heirs
don't know what that is hmm I honestly
don't know this one okay and this
doesn't make it easy it doesn't identify
the right answer you have to click on
all the ones to see if it's right so
that come on fix you goddamn quiz Jesus
Christ and don't time me out oh it is
now
Jenna's turn can you test I spill
lipstick in your blank bag
I don't I don't remember what she called
it it's like a white purse or something
light-colored and the mom was like wow
is that the one yeah and you have five
seconds I'm gonna say do you wear I
don't know not naughty or is it a longer
short I'm sorry it's a medium the long
word hmm
come on baby I'm trying okay so it's not
Chanel ten seconds five ten my what a
browner brands it's like designer brands
right you're thinking of theirs
Balenciaga there's three to final
answers about but can't just say
nonsense in over what is it Valentina
melty so I said Valentina
no easy ah Valentino I knew it okay it
is now Chris's turn you both got that
one wrong cool shame shame shame you are
my dad I'm trying to read them without
any tongue thank you you are my dad wait
this is a Gabriel gundeck Irvine yeah
you're my dad
you are my dad you're my dad boogie
woogie woogie yeah oh yeah oh that's
what you needed
you need to the boogie woogie okay sorry
well done yeah thanks Gabe I don't say
something bout a noodle head I was like
oh that's not that one was for something
it's much easier when you know the
answers they just say that for the
audience listening when you know the
answers you have in front of you this
quiz is a lot easier so I'm having an
easy time this one is in all caps and it
says you better blank
oh I thought I had it better stop
correct
stop you better stop that was it good
job
you better stop nice good job thanks
good time give me out again apparently
we're going very slow because it keeps
timing me the [ __ ] out well it things
that you're part of some guy on your
phone not doing it spot yes it is now
Chris's turn right yeah that was Jenna's
point Chris happy Christmas is Christmas
Merry Crisis blank merry Chrysler
correct yes Thanks for seeing all snap I
think we finished it that might have
been the last one
damn I'm behind - please don't okay
spoilers okay no there's more others boy
yeah Jenna get to Del Taco they got the
new thing blink free Sherlock can do
very good for you vaca do Chris I'm
doing it mother trucker dude that hurt
like a butt cheek on ink on a stick well
done Thank You Jenna it is blank my
dudes thank you they're good very good
so this one is for Chris yes sorry he's
being sly so basically um what I was
thinking of this um blank hmm basically
I'm I was thinking um isn't right what
this is a tough one so basically um but
I was thinking of this um blank hmm yeah
no idea go see you Jenna is that I put a
whole bag of jelly beans up my ass I
don't see what is a whole bag of jelly
beans in my ass that's that's probably
it actually I can't believe you've done
this
that was the end of it remember he's
talking he says so basically um what I
was thinking I think it's slightly as
punch
yeah I can't believe you've done now is
obscure that was [ __ ] obscure of all
that video it's like the most like
honest and like play way to react is on
punching your face I can't believe
you've done this okay whose turn is it
Chris
Janus Genesis I got that one car got
passed I want to be a blank baby yes I
know thank God I know this one ten
seconds five seconds all right Chris I
want to be a cowboy baby yeah that one's
great
it's like cigarette yeah sounds great
Chris now it is your turn
thank God a blank flew around my room
hmm
okay so this one's really easy I'm gonna
use my time here you just promote
something okay ten seconds oh hi
I'm scared ah potato that girl's also in
college slash by a CEO of a major
fortune 500 company now you frickin
Fricks
when will you learn this is the Jenna
when will you learn when will you learn
that was good job on Jenna's part
nosegay I would not have known that one
I didn't know it either I'm glad she's
give Chris a point not sure I gave you a
point you're at ten now still two behind
are they time to stop once again
come on app um Chris yes goes to you
daddy
blank Jenna I'm watching me and my plank
I'm watching me in my clothes I'm
watching here
go on I'm trying to read them like a
Syria would read them yeah he needs some
blank milk yo you need some milk now it
is Jenna's turn that was blank that was
blank
do you I'm gonna give you a little hint
tiny hint you give her child's a child
to sing it chitin Asst uh legit that was
great I met that kid
that was legitness okay Chris's turn
absolutely this is a really hard that is
a hard clue but you guys are hard ovine
Viner
people know okay you spent a lot of time
in the apps I don't give me those
excuses that's your other warning Chris
turn he in blank mode he an Eskimo
[Laughter]
I was in Sikkim oh that wasn't around
them Jenna sir
so you're just gonna bring me a birthday
gift on my birthday to my birthday party
on my birthday with a blank gift that is
so hard he just says birthday a million
times and then smashes a bottle on it so
a blank gift birthday thank you it's not
hard it's easy that's that I let our
Creator
yeah yeah all right that was it so after
quiz number one I'm gonna press quit
Chris is down by two points that's fair
it is a nail-biter neck-and-neck no this
is very entertaining I actually am way
more entertaining than I thought I would
be during this because I thought yeah
yeah some of these especially when I'm
reading them and they don't really I
know we both pulled out a few
interesting ones to or like oh wow but
then we also both [ __ ] up Christine's
which I feel terrible about yeah well
hey Christine I didn't [ __ ] anything up
with your zone you can please be mad at
them okay
you'd be an interesting quiz I don't
it's on there but one that I think would
be pretty cool is finishing tic toc
songs dude
that's a good idea dude feel free to
take that idea and use it okay but yes
now speaking of feel free me Andes feel
free collection is out now and basically
this collection focuses on real body
types not models not mannequins so the
feel free collection has sizes from
extra small to 4 XL okay a feather-light
waistband provides zero restriction and
much more freedom what me Andes is known
for I'm not wearing the feel free
collection but I'm wearing the regular
me Andy's collection and I can tell you
it is incredibly soft three times softer
than cotton three times softer than
cotton three times silent con I have to
say it three times the collection comes
with five new undies silhouettes
including a bralette for the least bra
bra you'll ever wear trust it doesn't
feel like it's there been wearing mine
all day even there they have fun new
prints that I drop it you or your onesie
literally all weekend hi dr. pineapple
one eye doctor I'm sorry it's a
comfortable onesie forget your gamer
onesie and it's like 95 degrees out that
shows you how how thin it is it is could
you please not fight your gamer ones I
actually recently got shipped a couple a
couple pairs of they have so they have a
bunch of designs and prints but they
have like solid colors too and I got
shipped a print or just like a plain
navy blue and I was like dude I [ __ ]
with the solid colors abs are really
nice and I like them and so I wore them
and you should too so go to me undies
comm slash gin Angelyn you get 15% off
and free shipping it's really a
no-brainer if you want really
comfortable underwear check it out
they have our stamp of approval but
Julien what if I'm on my phone well if
you're on your phone then you can go to
stitch fix because stitch fix has
clothing options for you that you don't
need to go into the store to buy similar
to me on these accept more than just
underwear they have clothes they have
jackets jeans shirts hats anything that
you can imagine that will dress you
stitch fix is there for you and if you
don't feel like going into the store and
trying things on you just say hey
I like wearing that thing and they show
you a picture you're like yes I like
that and then they show you know the
picture you're like nope not that and
then you done with the quiz it's not
just two questions long that was a
summary of it you're done with the quiz
they keep your profile and then they do
all the work they go back to their
science labs it's definitely a
scientific and they come up with the box
of clothing that's for you they send it
to your house
you don't have to check out it a
register you don't have to park in a
mall parking lot you don't have to do
any of the nonsense you let's go to the
food court
so go to the food court that's actually
sounds kind of nice no oh yeah yes no
the food curbs yes anyway go to stitch
fix comm slash Jenna Julianne get an
extra 25% off when you keep all the
items in your box or click link down
below to get a personal stylist that's
gonna shop for you I mean that's fancy
dude jeez Nancy [ __ ] fancy dude right
right babe no guys are posting a bang or
tik-tok to later today
based on a true story - yep ok so this
one is not on the internet and we're
gonna do another one but we're gonna
keep the same tally this shirt a
continuing scoreboard yes hey so calm
down everybody ok I'm calm I'm trying
seriously relax energies out of control
here
it's Virgo season she's loud to her she
wants how do you feel about that by the
way you're very far from the mic goosey
thank you please stay up on the mic so
we can hear you I don't want to hunch
over it feels weird I'm just gonna sit
like this don't do that why you just
told me to be up on the mic that's
actually pretty cool yeah thanks what's
good fam we don't have an arm ok those
are our podcasts
it's [ __ ] legit news thank you I'm
just trying to open a [ __ ] email
attachment there we go ok here we go it
is now Chris's turn is this lightning
round er no oh um no I'll do lightning
round
how many questions
maybe the last 10 questions yeah that's
a good idea the legs let's do the last
10 questions of lightning around it okay
okay
these means I'll say the question and
the first person shall the answer wins
hmm okay what are the better you'll let
us know the better speaking of which if
you're wearing shitty headphones or your
headphones are dialed very loud be
careful and what headphone users beware
this might get really loud be careful of
the lightning round for sure it's
capable of getting louder
have you ever watched one of my streams
my ears hurt okay it's Chris turn okay
okay mmm-hmm road work ahead
yeah sure hope it does he'll correct who
thought that that one was like just one
word yeah right
[ __ ] some of these are kind of obscure
um might be might be fun though it's
Jenna stop saying I look like hmm
Chrissy knows stop saying I look like I
think you might have seen this one but
it's definitely an obscure one yeah stop
saying it looked like oh dude I think I
know what it is can we get one hint it
starts with a see a chicken cutlet no
but close okay I'll see you stop saying
I look like chicken but five three
chicken wings Oh
zero that's not it that's not the
chicken nugget one no one says stop
saying look like Chicken Little he's
dumb and he's a coward and I'm not a
coward oh that's funny so no one got
that well this is like a this is like a
a rare vine this is a very like that
it's very obscure yeah whose turn that's
Christmas
no mm-hmm don't [ __ ] with me I blank
I have the power of God in anime on life
side thank you well done very good job
good delivery told you about the
headphones thing
do you remember bonus points well how do
you I'd yell that all the time you know
there's goes that's funny your character
looks like he would be that kind of okay
okay Chris yes this might trigger some
people stirs mac and cheese oh man I'd
say that or you don't have to get a
point can I like I'm gonna say it but
can we it was like off by a little bit
am I wrong I can bleep it out with my
mouth no no okay it's like it's like do
I'm gonna bleep it out of my mouth
so it it's like yeah do I'm gonna
believe it out with my mouth I'll bleep
that word out with my mouth okay no I
don't make sure I'm saying it correctly
I feel like I'm gonna say they're like
wrong words in order okay
that's the sound of good [ __ ] it's
actually not that wording but you got me
that's what good blank sounds okay give
me give me yeah you can have the poor
yeah thank you sorry but tonight yeah is
it all where the where the where the
moms like cooking she's like whoa yeah
ah it's like a little [ __ ] this one is
for where y'all going blank where y'all
going actually I'll extend it this is
hard where y'all going
why you need blank sounds like
conversation one princess where y'all
going the other person says why you need
it's like I know how it's said off the
cruise it's like where are y'all going
mmm-hmm and then why you need no you
just said what I said in a different
voice yeah okay a for effort for both
you but no it says where y'all going why
why he needs to know all up in my [ __ ]
boy yeah
to to pee ones back to back to pee ones
back to that thank you no I'm just
kidding
no ok we're not gonna do it
ok segue it is Chris's turn yeah all
caps
why will Cheyenne I'm kidding
all caps is it is there you're gonna add
one word what can you tell me how many
letters are or how many words are it's a
lot I mean it's one two three four five
class seven eight
why no okay why no I'll give you another
one
yeah I give another word yeah why are
why are oh man it's very [ __ ] hard
when you don't know like it's not just a
word yeah Wow why are why are this is
actually helping five seconds why don't
we get a third word like this isn't see
why are you why are you I
why are you okay this is gonna this is
this hold on hold on hold on this is now
officially the start of the lightning
round I'm gonna say it in a different
voice okay okay okay this is the
beginning of the lightning I'm down here
okay all right why are you running
Jenna why are you running ah man good
that's so hard though it is hard why it
is hard but I'm sorry is this the big
leagues or are you doing amateur hour
here that's not this is a grapefruit
league okay lightning round
thank you hey Terry
you want some this [ __ ] empty eat Nate
[ __ ] yeah this is a car it's also
physical and this is more intense
physical yeah I might do something now
okay what are those Christmas if your
name is jr. and raise your hand
simply Jenna she beat you and you were
wrong some words
hands up hey wait that's how I used to
play in my orchestra I was in middle
school I oh my god I played the trumpet
I'd be like you can't [ __ ] up if you
don't make anything I sucked yeah oh so
bad
remember to give your solos in front of
everyone I would be something yeah I was
sick
dude I was I was sick does this I was I
think of embarrassment
I dropped my French horn and it wasn't
mine and there was a big day you were a
French orner yeah chill out
sorry yeah I was first clarinet cuz I'm
over go I like perfection and I never
shadow played we are would you ever mess
round the elbow I like the elbow but I
didn't think with you I really liked it
still lightning round hmm all right yep
you have to explain this vine okay I'm
gonna say something that happens and you
have to explain it just say what's
happening in the point okay this kids
definitely on crack right now that's my
boy
twice timeout that was too close to call
so we're gonna have a reenactment
contest
Christopher okay so he's so he's on the
court he's wearing a little he's a
little outfit he's hidden head my barn
he goes he goes yeah if I recall this a
little bit more of a scream in it
okay he's like no I'm like okay he's
yeah he does exactly that he's like zero
Park he goes yeah just give us
everything else happened
notable ORS no all right I gotta give it
to her yeah yeah give it to understand I
had to lose this dance
she had the stance right apparently
getting hit in the head with basketballs
yeah okay
he's also probably in college now
Congrats and finishing
yeah first spring semester now he's
playful Congrats on your engineering
degree okay
Who am I let's go to a beach beach Nicki
Minaj is that a co-host one yeah damn
Corbin Bleu I'll get a puffer though I'm
gay I'm King okay where does this take
place this fine where does this take
place dad look it's the good Kush it's
in a Walmart it's gonna be if it's from
Walmart okay Chris it's in a Walmart
dollar store the dollar store how good
can it beat yeah that's funny Peter cute
okay
Matt King yep singing a song in the car
Beyonce baby yeah yeah Chris he said
Beyonce first even though I was gonna
ask the name of the song he got it right
sir well what is the name of the song
you just sing it and said Beyonce but us
with the song what you did lightning
round my fiance rules go by Aries rules
in lightning round okay maybe it's you
it's a love on top on top on top you
know what I'll give you both the point
yeah video is up you can both have a
point for that Chris you need a definite
line dude okay I got peach holding me
right now what's better than this what's
better than this two guys being dude
dudes but then this guy's being dudes
guys nice good job Chris gets it
what's better than this guys being dudes
you know what I love myself you know
what I look like a burnt chicken nugget
jenna is so [ __ ] I'm fine damn okay
you know what I love myself even I look
like a chicken ooh that was actually I
better thank you that was a better job
acting it out even though you beat him I
kiss a boss at a company now Chris is
like estimation of where they are in
life now like keep doing that that's
funny okay thanks a little bit okay I'm
Pete help me out okay
girl honks the car horn while her mom is
walking in front of it causes her to
throw something what is she gone a milk
I didn't know you're gonna ask what it
was it sorry
hey those are grand MA to be honest yeah
I think so she was great
yeah shoots that ceiling this is why mom
doesn't [ __ ] love you
damn dude that is so hard how did you
get that I own oh hi my name is Trey and
I got smoked in borrow I'm a point card
I got shoe game if you got that wrong I
think you would have had to legally just
give your mistake in the podcast of
Chris yeah been a Jenna narwhals it's
over party if you got that wrong site
but you got a right so we're fine
oh hi welcome to Chili's thanks for
checking in I'm still a piece of garbage
no worse I'm really sorry I didn't mean
to do that I really didn't mean to
deducting a point from Jenna oh please
that's good Oh still appears I'm gonna
ban and they release whoa actual tie we
are going down to the reenactment
version Jenna you go first reenact this
all this we can focus on your acting so
there's the woman walking by and she's
like and they were roommates and then he
goes in named little moon means Chris
hurt em sounds good so she's walking by
when roaming so she's walking by but she
has her sunglasses on and headphones
then details and she's like and they
were roommates and he goes and they were
roommates it's hard because it's a guy
who says it sounds a lot more like Chris
but it's also it's also in New York City
and she's on the sidewalk
more details also it looks like Brooklyn
honestly you know it could be could
potentially be Lower East Side also but
it could be Williamsburg tip it was do
you think boy it can be Boston [ __ ] it's
definitely lower Manhattan I think
anyway I don't know much your West Coast
yeah yeah he's got something we all have
a lot of laughs okay okay [ __ ] off [ __ ]
off wait we all had a lot of laughs [ __ ]
off why do you keep making sus eye
contact with Chris he's in my eyeline
what
let me just turn my whole body to look
at you wait so we all have a lot of last
[ __ ] off we all have a lot of laughs
[ __ ] off Janet [ __ ] off [ __ ] it's a guy
in target [ __ ] off Janet no it's a guy
at work I don't give a [ __ ] about your
baby shower your kids baby showers I'm
not going your [ __ ] baby shower
that's it yes yeah all right you're
three behind I know
and there's one question left one
question left okay this is worth three
actually there's a couple I skipped
earlier ah man okay I complained explain
this fine
hmm okay hey man can I have some beer
what's happening when the guy says hey
man can have some beer there's a dog in
it
hmm I have no idea I don't think I've
ever seen this fun hey man got some beer
that's a dog no no no go nuts get that
one hmm hmm dumb ready
Marlene your speech was so good Oh like
I didn't even try it was just improv oh
wait is that a um good meal monster all
mm-hmm
Marlene you still good I got an even try
so it's like whatever why'd you take the
[ __ ] compliment oh oh it's it's it's
Maya Maya oh my god just take the
compliment
into the funny face I was a really good
vine
yep that was the Jenna damn it dude
she's an astronaut school now okay
that's one she is a [ __ ] [ __ ] no
mm-hmm she's the [ __ ] yeah bi see th is
that a fine you know no I don't know it
either no points for anyone
you know what I don't want to end on
that one let's end on a better one a
man's fine
I lose let's find no no oh this is it's
called drug or Pokemon really odd one
that one for sure
Pokemon master
you know Pikachu I know okay this is
gonna be solely an impression one I'm in
my mum's car
it's each have your turn okay Chris goes
first I'm in me mom's car wrong wrong
okay Jenna I'm in me mum's car so you
did the beat get out get out me car room
its broom well you know what then that's
fun
Chris you put up a [ __ ] sick fight
but you lost by five points okay and you
know what I think we're all winners
today yeah yeah we are
but still it's fun play with Chris cuz
he like knows yeah what do we do last
time it was just you quizzing yourself
yeah like now we had a worthy opponent
yeah cuz I'm not working I'm coming back
longer than ever next time oh damn he's
[ __ ] calling you out for the next one
he wants the rematch already oh well we
are out of time we were getting rushed
off the stage and Chris has a flight but
time to get him on his flight your
flights on the runway that's what time
it is
oh yeah I gotta leave eval Italy in
Italy right now yeah anyway thank you
guys for listening I hope you enjoyed
the vine trivia quiz the vine 1v1 the
intense vine showdown of the century if
you don't follow Chris you can find him
online at Chris Mel burger will link his
stuff below he's on Twitter very funny
on Twitter streams all the time on
Twitch really awesome community over
there the burger shack
he makes cool tic TOCs one and two of
which I have recently starred in very
proud of those yes please watch them and
retake them and REE talk them and thank
you for joining us on the podcast it was
a lot of fun to have you back I'm sorry
we couldn't have Shen but we still have
fun yeah
no absolutely I appreciate guy saw me on
and let's do Dan soon let's do it again
soon and congrats on everything going on
with me too
and I hope some cool stuff happen soon I
mean I mean that'd be like so weird and
crazy anyway have a good flight Chris
you guys have a good week we'll see on
the next one bye say guys GG's
[Music]